in jiu-jitsu i telegraphed my moves when
i focus on whatever escape or submission
i'm attempting and it's pretty obvious
to who I'm training with how do I learn
to work on a particular move while
actually setting up another move at the
same time essence of the Dave birth
question by the way interesting yeah
okay so good question and actually
reveal something pretty cool about
jiu-jitsu in many cases in jiu-jitsu
especially in like the first three to
five years of training and that that's a
pretty big span but what's interesting
about is is that the setups for moves
are actually other moves right so and
you actually have to attempt the other
move legitimately in order for it to
work as a setup so if you're mounted on
someone and you want to arm lock
somebody don't grab their arm that's the
Telegraph what you do is you go for the
choke and you don't just fake go for the
choke yeah go for the choke you put
those you dig him you grab some ghee you
start to attack their net and and
obviously if they don't defend then you
choke them which is awesome
but you can you go for the choke for
real but if they lift up their arm to
defend their neck which they should do
then boom they are mocked exposed and
you take it that's the way it works and
the same thing goes with Camaros and
look like the Chimaera sweep guillotine
you know that combo from the guards it's
really like a basic one that you learn
so yeah bum sweep the Chimaera and the
guillotine from the guard the the
defense for each one of those is the
setup for the other and and there's so
many you know jiu-jitsu like that's what
did you do is right I mean it's like
triangle arm lock it's it's just that's
the way it is yeah you have to commit to
the moves you can't just like if you do
a half-hearted attempt to do a sit-up
sweep on me I'm not gonna give you the
reaction that you need to get Agee to
owe me right if you don't push me back
hard enough I'm not gonna lean forward
enough to grab my neck
yeah so it's not gonna work
now as you progress in jiu-jitsu you you
able to start attacking other things
like for instance you can attack
someone's balance as a setup you can
attack their base you can attack their
posture as a setup you can attack their
arm position so you can attack and the
better you get at digit so you can
attack some conceptual things yeah Dean
said something like that the other day I
was like dang that's the smartest what
he was saying was he's like hey the he
said the person on the bottom can't fall
down profound yeah right the person on
the bottom can't fall down yeah you
can't you can't mess with my balance at
all but I can mess with if you're on top
I can mess with your bouncing that's one
of the key things that I try and mess
with your balance you can't mess with my
balance I'm on the ground yeah think
about that well actually you did say
that that Dean said that but um I I
don't know if you said that um you can't
knock me down when I'm on that yeah yeah
well that may be the way I put it but
that's that truth
let's see these principles obviously
they apply not only to jujitsu but they
apply to the battlefield they apply to
business because if you fake a frontal
assault to expose the enemy's flank mm
but you don't put enough firepower in
the frontal assault then the enemy
doesn't have to react to it
mm so they just kind of keep their
perimeter secure and then when you flank
them their flank is defended yeah so
it's the same exact thing yeah you have
to commit enough to throw the person's
to to make the person react if you don't
give them enough they're not gonna react
in the business world if you come up
with a if you put up a new product to
contend with your competitor in some
market but the product isn't strong
enough that it becomes any kind of
threat well then the competitor isn't
have to contend with it at all and
you've actually wasted effort so if
you're gonna go go
go get the reaction that you need if
you're gonna execute a move to set up
your opponent it has to be strong enough
to elicit a really real reaction that's
- hmm you know you could do something
that's like a little distraction that's
a little different than a setup
yeah right you can distract someone
usually the distraction is much more
minor than a real set up yeah I can get
you thinking about something else why go
over here yeah not as effective yeah but
it has its times yeah yeah the
interesting I think they've mentioned
that idea to me before with this is a
question from David Ray Tucker oh yeah
so and here's another thing Dave Burke's
kind of early in in the in the game
today which is a good thing because he's
thinking about this stuff already yeah
but I think generally speaking like
these those types of tactics like where
I'm gonna go for this and then when he
reacts to that thing I went for then I'm
gonna really do my real move kind of
thing and then there can be chains too
by the way I can do yeah yeah yes and
the more you advance - people get when
they're really get stuck the more that
you'll see so but being early on or the
more of it you won't see I remember when
Dean and I were training like maniacs
and people would watch us and it barely
even like you did - because the
movements were so subtle like you
sometimes you would he was like I would
just feel his weight shift and I would
immediately weight shift my weight and
so there's three or four offensive and
defensive moves that happen and there's
barely any movement that's visual
because it's all in the weight yeah yeah
so when you mean when you don't see it's
like it's just so subtle that you don't
see you can visually see it but it's
yeah toe but totally still there of
course so that's that's kind of good
that he I think any way that he's
thinking that you know how to do that
yeah I think what's more important given
the stage and this is real generally
speaking because people are different
but learn them the moves you know the
crisp like mouhot like how to do an
armlock where your hips should be and
shouldn't be and what makes a arm lock a
good arm lock and one makes an arm lock
for example a bad arm lock you know
where it's like you know how some guys
can do an arm lock but it's like super
easy to escape because you have these
three details that you just didn't do
even though you know what an arm lock is
kind of thing so I think I think anyway
that when we
you start to get those things down your
brown belt Noah yeah oli yeah yeah yeah
he he's got a good arm lock yeah you
gotta watch out for that thing but he's
an example of like his arm lock is
really good and everyone's got their
really good moves yeah yeah good example
and when when when you get and you know
a handful of those down or you just your
general game down in in that particular
way then you can start like leaking into
that kind of way of thinking where it's
like okay I'm gonna go for this arm lock
you know and then I I'm not sure a
hundred percent disagree with you
because in my mind if you don't set
things up they're not gonna work yeah so
you have to set them up and you have to
start learning where that set up looks
like yeah but as I mean Dave Burke is at
that position right now this distant
moves are not working because he's not
setting him up because he's telegraphing
him yeah so he that's why he's asking
the question yeah so when you I this is
the this is the answer to when that
question comes which it will when you
start training jiu-jitsu and you start
training against people that know what
you know or at least some of what you
know yeah they're gonna defend yeah and
its proper that they defend because
their defense is a set up for your next
move yeah that's the part you got to
realize yeah so considered and when he
asked me this before or when he talked
about I forget exactly when it was I I
was considering it through his point of
view right or and in with an expert okay
so but whose point of view and my point
of view so if I'm rolling with a white
belt and like a real new white belt and
he's doing the move that they learned
that day so he's doing it step by step
by the way he learned and I'm like okay
this is that's the ultimate in
telegraphing by the way when you're
looking at the steps that you just
watched him learn kind of thing you
might even add it to him on so when they
do that it's I think that's appropriate
as far as the learning process early on
it's like yeah get those down practice
that part of it yeah it's not gonna work
it in fact it might work on another
super new new guy yeah and and yeah I
know I've rolled with guys dean is one
of them
where he you know where he's gonna do
yeah you know what he's gonna do he
might as well tell you yeah what he's
gonna do and and he's gonna do it
yeah now sometimes you give up like you
give up an inch and all of a sudden you
feel it and you go
my arm is exposed yeah and you and you
spend the next two minutes defending
that arm and there's nothing you can do
to stop it
right but and I think we both know that
that's so much different in this way
because if Dean's like okay man that's
so multi-dimensional compared to like a
white belt a weight belt Telegraph
e-news moves cuz Dean okay Dean for
example he's like I'm gonna get mount
and I'm a dormer so him getting mount is
gonna be all these little micro like
things in there yeah not to mention the
psychological war that he just waged on
you and he's ahead by the way so you got
that and then you got all these little
things when he goes for mount he's just
gonna he's just gonna get mount so to
get mount you got to do a certain you
know thing in his case so when he does
those things that's gonna be a bunch of
those things that you're talking about
all this thing I'm gonna fake this site
but then I'm gonna go this site but I'm
gonna shift my weight so he shifts his
weight that way of so he so I go here so
you know so there's little mini things
but he's just so good at it that he'll
do he can just do it like that true so I
think I mean again the the point there
is like it's a lot different with a guy
who Dean when he says I'm gonna get
mount and I'm an armbar you he's not
telegraphing anything he's telling you
sure but he's not technically
telegraphing like it like a white belt
situation but either way I get it either
way I mean everyone's different um I do
think that learning those steps and
learning what a good I think getting
that part down early on early on is is I
think more foundational its foundational
once you start asking the question why
won't anyone tap to my moves I need to
set them up better here you go yeah yes
I think you're about that you know to
your point now you when you want to do
so it's kind of like a feint right and
boxy maybe a little bit more like I said
I'm gonna when I go for a move as this
as a setup move
you got us really sell that move you got
to really be going for this so it's like
bait right but yeah in fact you ever
watch the movie bait no ok so bait is
moving with Jamie Foxx and you know some
other people anyway so one of the guys
it's so they're trying to catch this did
this gold thief right in bit so let's
gold thief it but he's a real genius
computer nerd Goldthwait and he's super
good at hiding the way the way you
pronounce that you like gold thief okay
this is it's gold
the criminal but he's like a computer
guy you know a super genius easy like
hides really well and super hard to find
and all this stuff and so the guy that
FBI guy whoever you know the law
enforcement dude he's like hey we gotta
set some bait so this guy comes out and
gets the bait but when you set bait you
can't be some fake thing if this bait
has to be real like a war you know when
you try to catch a wolf the bait has to
be real it can't be just some bait you
bought kind of kinda idea so you know so
the idea of the movie is they get this
guy Jamie Foxx and they make him the
bait but he doesn't know he's the bait
because he has to be real has to be he
can't be tainted with the human scent he
got to be a real life piece of bait so
that's essentially what your moves gotta
be absolutely you gotta be like hey look
if my bait is the armlock if I'm gonna
bait the Camorra to get this it up sweep
that Kimura gotta be a fresh plucked out
of the wild Kimura attempt and then when
he goes and reacts to it bites it boom I
get to sit up sweet same exact thing so
yeah that got us the the setup move got
a smell real got a smell real I like to
keep all my moves
smelling super real who's insane